stephanie fugaz arbitra de fútbol
francesa sigue rompiendo récords fue la
primera juez de la liga francesa la
primera en dirigir un partido de
selecciones nacionales fue también
pionera en arbitrar en la competición de
la europa league y ahora lo ha hecho en
la champions league la máxima
competición de clubes europea con el
partido juventus dinamo de kiev un nuevo
hito a sus 36 años con el que seguir
abriendo puertas a las mujeres en el
fútbol masculino
[Música]
también en fútbol pero americano
continúan los avances en igualdad sara
fuller de la universidad de vanderbilt
fue la primera mujer en participar en un
partido de power five la ronda de
partidos más importantes del fútbol
americano universitario es todo lo que
quiero conseguir es ser una buena
influencia para las chicas jóvenes
porque he tenido que luchar mucho en el
mundo del deporte sin embargo estoy
agradecida por haber podido salir
adelante extranjero lo más curioso es
que fue la gran esport era de fútbol sin
embargo también espaciadora de fútbol
americano femenino y ahora de masculino
donde se estrenó con una patada baja de
30 yardas
la inclusión va más allá del deporte y
llega al mundo de los tatuajes en
afganistán
soraya se agita a sus 27 años se ha
convertido en la primera tatuadora del
país tras haber adquirido sus
habilidades cuando fue refugiada en irán
y turquía
podría haber desarrollado esta profesión
en el extranjero pero quería hacerlo en
afganistán porque no hay mujeres
tatuadores en el país en mi opinión no
sólo los hombres pueden hacer tatuajes
también las mujeres
túnez además soraya ofrece extensión de
pestañas y servicios de manicura
servicios que estuvieron prohibidos
entre 1996 y 2001 durante el gobierno
del talibán
[Música]
el arte también permite avanzar en los
derechos de las mujeres transgénero en
pakistán chandan y es una mujer trans
que en el pasado tuvo que bailar por
dinero así como mendigar por las calles
ahora gracias a magnus una ong de ayuda
a las personas trans que andan y elabora
piezas decorativas de arte que han
llegado a mostrarse en exposiciones y
luego que ahora la gente nos respeta y
podemos vivir una vida normal porque hay
muchos pedidos de clientes me siento
feliz por poder obtener respeto gracias
a nuestro trabajo candelabros bandejas
de madera lámparas todo tipo de objetos
con los que desarrollan sus capacidades
en un país que se estima que tiene 300
mil personas transgénero
en nepal que las mujeres toquen un
cadáver era un tabú sin embargo a raíz
de la pandemia mujeres soldado han
tenido que manejar cuerpos de víctimas
del cob y 19 un escenario inimaginable
hace unos años
antes a las mujeres no se les permitía
acercarse a los cadáveres ni tocarlos
fue un desafío para nosotras y teníamos
dudas de si podríamos hacerlo
convertimos el desafío en una
oportunidad y lo hicimos con éxito nepal
de mayoría hindú salió de un conflicto
de una década en 2006 después en 2008
abolió su monarquía feudal centenaria y
poco a poco las mujeres han podido ir
ganando más derechos
y